bonsoir d'anvers merci d'être avec nous
la justice qui refusons des strade mais
qui gardent en prison julien assange
qu'est ce que ça dit selon vous je crois
qu'on est tous d'accord tous ceux qui en
france en tout cas et soutiennent le
blaco de la salle c'est complètement
incohérent parce que dans la mesure où
la logique judiciaire n'est pas
respectée on la juge en le considère que
ya pas matière à l'extrader et en même
temps elle le garde en détention
je précise qu'en france d'ailleurs ça ne
serait pas possible parce que on
distinguerait quelques années le juge
qui poursuit ou qui parlent anglais
instruction et qu'on a inventé il ya
10-15 ans qui est le juge des libertés
et de la détention qui n'est pas le même
donc là on a une espèce d'incohérences
puisque d'un côté elle explique que l
l'expédient pas aux états unis et on y
est évidemment ravi parce que pour des
raisons de santé pourraient pas soutenir
la détention là bas mais en même temps
elle le laisse donc une prison qui est à
peu près l'équivalent de certaines
prisons américaines c'est quand même une
prison de haute sécurité où il n'a rien
à faire de toute manière quitte une
présence très difficile il est en
détention depuis maintenant un an et
demi il a passé faut pas l'oublier dans
l'ambassade des années terribles à
savoir tous les matins à s'il allait
être remis ou pas aux américains
c'est une situation psychologique donc
très difficile donc il ya une
incohérence absolue qui est très
étonnante
bon il faut savoir aurait dû voir la
dépêche tout à l'heure que les avocats
anglais font appel de la décision donc
de cette décision de maintien en
détention
je vais pas la date précise mais on
espère que ce sera assez vite puisque il
ya à l'évidence en tout cas peut-être un
embarras mais une stratégie de le
laisser c'est une stratégie possible le
laisser mourir en prison c'est ce que
nous en redoutent depuis très longtemps
ça a été très long à venir cette
audience
et ça risque d'être encore très long
jusqu'à ce que la cour d'appel à la cour
en angleterre examine son appel donc le
bon sens et l'honnêteté juridique
logique c'est de dire laisser le libre
il a il a deux petits enfants il a une
heure il à son épouse huma pas
s'échapper
bon enfin on n'imagine pas assange en
angleterre aujourd'hui libre s'échapper
parce que il y là il aura envie de se
défendre
je ne prends pas savoir ce qui se passe
dans sa tête mais c'est complètement
incohérent sur le plan simplement du
droit et de la logique juridique c'est
ce que tous les gens alors on est
content évidemment que ce soit un avis
défavorable à l'extradition
même s'il est juridiquement pas très
très structuré il a fallu attendre la
dernière page du jugement pour que pour
savoir quelle est la juste la juge ne
l'enverrai pas aux états unis en l'état
mais un appel des américains donc pour
l'instant on est dans cette situation
assez bizarre où il est maintenu en
détention ce qui est pas cohérent du
tout qui est pas logique
alors je parle pas du côté militant
évidemment il n'a rien à faire en prison
mais ça c'est un point de vue militant
et personnel que du point de vue de
juristes c'est pas cohérent et on espère
que la cour d'appel
aujourd'hui la cour d'appel highco a va
statuer rapidement le plus rapidement
possible et va le libérer éventuellement
sous caution c'est ce qu'on fait ce
après midi l'avocat anglais même si les
poursuites demain et c'est loin d'être
fini évidemment puisque on ne sait pas
quand aura lieu le procès en appel
on ne sait pas ce que vont faire les
américains ou pas mais enfin ils n'ont
pas l'air de vouloir abandonner la
partie nulle part vous pas non plus trop
rêver sur le nouveau président sur on
l'espère aussi
donc nous nous nous maintenons notre
position depuis des mois et des mois qui
est celle de beaucoup de qu'on a fait
une sorte de collectif un fort mal de
gens qui sont actifs en france pour
défendre un centre qui est de dire
l'asile politique parce que nous on est
intraitable là dessus je rappelle que on
le demande nous depuis des mois je
rappelle que celui qui était l'avocat
d'assange mais qui est pas resté très
longtemps c'est à dire le ministre de la
justice avait annoncé cor et à cri à dix
huit mois qu'il allait demander l'asile
on en a plus entendu parler nous avons
sollicité des députés et on continue à
le faire et tous ceux qui peuvent nous
écouter sont invités à le faire déposer
des questions écrites on a obtenu que
jean lassalle dépôt d'une question orale
on a vu tous il ya trois mois la réponse
misérable du ministre le drian qui a
expliqué que hassan je n'étais pas en
danger que tout allait très bien pour
lui bon maintenant on peut considérer ça
puisque il n'est pas en danger la
famille dans une prison de haute
sécurité il est en mauvaise santé et ya
aucune raison de le maintenir dans cette
prison donc première chose il faut le
libérer et si la france veut bien se
rappeler qu'elle est la france il faut
lui offrir l'asile et ça personne ne l'a
vraiment officiellement demandé à
monsieur macro qui s'est abrité derrière
monsieur le drian qui était assez
misérable à l'assemblée assez médiocre
en lisant des fiches donc plus que
jamais nous demandons au président de la
république français d'accorder l'asile
ce qui paraît de bon sens parce qu'il
serait très difficile aux anglais de
refuser je rappelle quand même et c'est
il faut le saluer que le président du
mexique
dès lundi a offert l'asile a proposé
l'asile au mexique
il a été un des chefs d'état s'est
engagé très tôt pour en faveur de
l'asile poids salle nous c'est une
hypothèse puisque un sage le souhaitent
ils l'avaient fait dire à plusieurs
reprises il avait fait dire cette année
par dupont moretti l'asile pour être
parfaitement cohérent il y avait qu en
france il a un enfant majeur qui est en
france qui pas vieux ça serait élégant
et ça serait bien qu'est ce qui fait que
dupont moretti a trahi un point de vue
l'a trahi il a une parle plutôt de
l'asile maintenant qu'il est ministre
donc nous continuons par des pétitions
par des appels aux députés français et
au sénateur a demandé l'asile plus que
jamais parce que ça peut être une façon
de le faire sortir
on soutient évidemment et on espère
qu'il va être remis en liberté on
appelle dans les jours qui viennent le
plus vite possible même si on n'a pas ce
soir la date est bien sûr on espère un
arrêt des poursuites mais il faut pas
trop rêver dans l'immédiat il faut
qu'ils puissent continuer à se défendre
à l'ombre libre avec en étant une des
conditions de défense normes allons
pouvoir voir ses avocats n'étant pas
dans ce cachot de haute sécurité
parce que là encore une fois la logique
nous échappe complètement
on nous dit en refusant de l'extrader
aux états unis parce qu'ils seraient
dans des conditions absolument
insupportable psychologiquement et c'est
vrai
marcy pardonnez moi on arrive à la fin
de notre temps en tout cas on a compris
évidemment votre message que la france
pourrait jouer un rôle à dans cette
affaire pour faire sortir éventuellement
avec une demande d'asile
je viens assange merci beaucoup à vous
françois cambert un délégué général de
l'association robin des